It was shortly after meeting drones,
tracter Fitch that I realized that
joining the Marine Corps might've been a
bad decision.
All right,
come from brains.
Show me exactly where your stubies I'm
running.
No,
I never boot camp instructors doing
amount of tech.
What?
I'm giving you a few love taps.
How the fuck are you going to fire your
right bow when grenades are going up in
your face?
What the fuck are you even doing here?
Sorry,
I got lost on the [inaudible].
Okay.
Now some of you might've noticed that
I've placed the original opening sound
check of giants,
bobby mcferrin.
Don't worry,
be happy with the opening sound.
Check off the 90 86 film full metal
jackets.
Now,
although I have copyright reasons for
this,
I also think it's essential to analyze
jarhead within the context of full metal
jacket because of its similarities,
birth even more because of its
differences.
Now,
jars refuse upon release were quite
mixed and many were even negative.
Leslie Valparin described jarred as
critical as claimed that it has little
new to say,
and Joshua Moon stated that the film
goes nowhere,
but two major paradoxical criticism
stood out.
Joe teachy claimed that barely a frame
wheel feel to remind it's audience off
another seminar war movie.
It's effectively the Iraq of date.
Oh,
full metal jacket.
Yes.
All this claim,
the film fell out of genre as a warm
movie since there were no battles being
fought.
Yes,
I was argued that in this paradox of
both relying on other warfiles while
also not adhering to the Warfield Sharma
lays,
jr has cental team.
Now,
both films start out with a brutal
bootcamp off the United States Marine
Corps.
The recruits are broken down into films,
both through verbal sauce
or you have a girlfriend.
Swapper sorry,
I started this again,
mother fucker.
Jody's banging her right now.
Get on your face and give me 25 per
every time she gets fucked.
This month down on your face
and through physical training.
Oh,
that's right.
Private mile.
Don't make any fucking up to get up to
the top of the fucking cops to go.
God want to do up there.
He went up very cold.
Your ass up there by now.
One night.
Get your bags up there.
Pile.
The hell is the matter with your buddy.
What?
I bet you if there was some punchy up
there on top of that off,
you can get up there,
Joe.
Yeah.
John resembles this process closely to
watch what is shown in full metal jacket
from the verbal assault and equal
woodless nurse without racism.
Speech.
No ratio.
Bigger three here.
I do not look down on niggers cuts.
What?
They're grazer.
Hey,
are you all all equally worthless?
You are no longer black or brown or
yellow or red.
You are now,
you are like food or dark boon.
Do you understand
any car?
Two to the glorification of marine
marksman ship and reshaping of marines
into coal hearts killers.
The Marine Corps does not want robots.
The Marine Corps wants killers.
The Marine Corps wants to build
indestructable men.
We're going to kick a rock.
Yes.
Oh hell son.
What are you going to win the medal of
honor all by yourself?
What's the rest of my battalion going to
do?
Jake?
Yes,
you know,
I think it's time for me to retire.
I can't hear how fucking day
I just got off.
Hard off.
Yes,
it is in the second part by jar has
quickly starts to differ from
expectations.
Jarheads shows us the marines in the
deserts aware that there a war going on
that's enabled to participate.
Yeah.
Suggested techniques for the marine to
use and the avoidance of boredom and
loneliness.
Masturbation,
rereading of letters from unfaithful
wives and girlfriends,
cleaning your rifle,
further masturbation.
It is here where the central team of
chartered slowly becomes apparent.
Our full metal jacket is critical of the
Marine corpse and the war.
The marines went a full combat in
Vietnam are functioning even when chaos,
psoriasis in the heat of battle,
they prevail and return back to order.
However,
in jarhead the second part of the movie
is a long and grueling process of
waiting boredom and living in the desert
without any contact with outside world
back home.
Life goes on and their relationships
fall apart.
She up there yet.
Don't worry,
she will.
She'll be right there.
She's going to look beautiful up there.
The Marines aimlessly patrolled the
deserts in harbor oilfields get bombed
by mortars but never see the enemy.
It is here that the film breaks with
hands.
Robert Jars calls to your rising of
expectations,
but the viewer's expectations of a war
film and the Marines expectations off
the work at Cheddar before the marines
leave.
The film shows them getting riled up
with the perspective of to grow his ride
of the valkyries scene in apocalypse
now,
shaping their few or fought a war will
be like
all personnel are to report immediately
to your company or
yes,
you to spend this juxtaposition to film
state.
Something about a different sort of wars
and the experiences of the marines in
these wars.
That's one of them.
Reads,
realizes how different this blog will
be.
He Commons.
Look around.
You hear those fights.
This board's going to move too fast for
us.
All right,
we can shoot a thousand yards to go that
far and Vietnam and take a week or one a
year here.
Can I take about 10 fucking seconds?
By the time we have our rifles style,
the war is going to be a mile down the
road
wake up.
But besides the new technological
reality of the war,
the more important statement to feel
makes is on the psychological impact of
being in the war or in this case not
being in the war in a sense,
being broken down and then rebuild as
supposed Koolhaas killing marines in the
Marine Corp bootcamp booth enabled to
apply this mindset and acquired skills
leads to just as much of a mental
breakdown as the horror.
So full combat.
The film shows us the slow descent of
the marines into these mental breakdowns
with,
of course,
Jake,
Jen,
last character Swafford at the center,
multiple moments than out one of the
marines breaks down when he finds out
his wife is cheating on him.
Sorry.
When a fellow marine gets him into
trouble,
swafford breaks down completely
the fuck up.
Shut the fuck up.
Shut the fuck out.
My repeat after me.
This is my rifle.
There are many like it without me.
My rifle
went down,
my rifle,
I
shut the fuck up.
Shut the fuck.
Fuck you.
Show me.
No.
Wow.
And finally,
what Swafford gets a chance to shoot at
an enemy.
The opportunity is taken away at the
last moment.
This is all for fun anyway.
Well,
wait,
not alive.
What difference does it make you come
back to him?
Because we got the Goddamn shut.
Your fucking desk jockey and the fucking
bracket or
nope.
The film shows us how to offer
experiences of this bar are completely
different than from other wars you have.
Not less awful.
It is this message that reconciles the
paradox of being a different war film
and also leaning on its predecessors is
paradox,
becomes the central team and is summed
up in the film in one sentence.
Every worse,
different.
Every war is the same
kettle drum
swallow to boots.
Dale
shoes.
Thank you all so much for watching.
So we had a bit of a break since
university began.
Birthday will be new videos in the
coming weeks.
We also started a patron.
A,
we're still very small,
but every little bit helps us to make
better videos.
Uh,
but more importantly,
we wanted to start giving additional
content from those that are interested
in it.
So for example,
if you support us with $1,
you get a video preview of the next
video before it comes out.
If you support us with $2,
you get access to written essays with
additional thoughts and information.
After each video,
$5,
we will get you an exclusive video once
a month.
Uh,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
This was of course,
completely optional.
Add a youtube sas will always be free.
So no problem if you aren't interested
in any case,
thank you for watching and we will see
you next week when the next video is
released.